2459 up there we all heard this girl
screaming bloody murder and help me
troubling body camera footage
foreshadows the murder of 33-year-old
Kyla AR when First Responders are called
to her home just one month before her
boyfriend allegedly killed her what's
your first name uh Kyla k y l a a r c e
whoa whoa whoa k y l a a r c e a r c e
yes how
you authorities say this man 32-year-old
Paul Henry diino shot and killed AR on
October 23rd at his parents home in
Coral Springs Florida officials say DJ
asento also tried to kill his father
attempting to shoot him and smother him
with a pillow DG asto's father later
told First Responders he survived by
playing dead when officials arrived on
the scene DG aino refused to come out of
his parents house after more than an
hour the standoff ended when DG ginto
was taken into custody once they entered
the home investigators found AR in the
living room she was pronounced dead on
the scene officials say DG rinto shot
and killed her more than a month before
all this Broward County sheriff's
deputies were called to the townhouse R
and DG asento shared in nearby pompo
Beach and the woman screamed help me
bloody murder basically I opened the
door and door open the door and then she
got back in closed the door and you hear
tons of Stu
screaming and knocking around sounds
like there's a struggle going on inside
basically struggle going on over there
yeah and I would totally like I want to
make sure she's okay Broward County
Sheriff's stues responded to the
townhouse on September 17th after
multiple neighbors reported disturbing
screams coming from the couple's
homeate got a picture of the roommate
car out of there I took a picture of his
car driving out yeah not took a picture
of his wife place to drove away yeah the
roommate came out of the building and
said that the guy is not abusive and
that's his best friend and he's known
him forever and when I asked him well
why would a female scream at the top of
her lungs help me he just goes I don't
know and then he walks away and leaves
so the roommates inside there too there
there was there was two guys the
roommate left he got this gentl right
here got a picture of his car I got
three people talking to me Sor First
Responders on the scene make their way
to the couple's door and begin
knocking
R out of Sheriff's
Office with multiple sheriff's deputies
on the scene these same moments are
caught on body camera recordings from
different
angles
right kind of Sheriff's
[Music]
Office this happens all the time
but I kind of Sheriff's Office that
guy
scares do you hear it still in your
apartment or no you're at the door so
open it up every day every day here I
can hear you at the door open the door
it's a sheriff's
office all right due to exent
circumstances we're 104 due to exiting
circumstances if we have to go ahead and
break the door down or get someone with
the key to open the door we will we just
need to find out if everybody's okay as
the knocking continues a neighbor can be
hurt telling sheriff's deputies he's
scared of the man inside that guy he
scares do you hear it still in your
apartment or no you're at the door so
open it up every day every day I can
hear you at the door open the door it's
the sheriff's
office after about 10 minutes of banging
on the door sheriff's deputies plan to
break it down exent circumstances
somebody yelling in out they said they
this heard anything you got here yeah
they come up to the door and they kind
of you can hear you can hear them
ressing up against they probably looking
at you right
now9 they don't this don't have have to
go this far but these people want to
make it seem like I mean if they want
their door open for that's okay that's
fine about to Happ cuz the fire the fire
rescue going come and open this door and
then we going to come in L 5 can you
have rescue respond out here help us
with some for
entry matter we this come through we
going have fire rescue wait for fire and
rescue to arrive First Responders give
the couple one last chance to open up
it's your last
chance come out to the
door when they still refuseed to open
the door additional First Responders
break it down all right we got fire
rescue here this is just me being
instructional to you I want you to
listen up fire rest is going to come and
they're going to go ahead and breach the
door it's going to be damag to this door
so I don't I just advise you to open the
door now for us to find out if they have
to breach the door people are going to
be putting handcuffs into detain until
we find out what's going on this just my
warning to you my first and final
warning these moments are again captured
from multiple angles neighbors heard
somebody yelling screaming they heard
glass breaking they heard uh Furniture
being thrown around
let's try this door I mean
it's try to hide I just whack that
the goddamn uh AC it's we try to
least minimal damage or it's not going
to it like that
yeah is he going arrest something well
we make sure she's okay right now it's a
w check based on the extended
circumstances to
get
you
need you
might you need a second set of hands I
just want my
head
you might have to go
high there you
go it's only after the front door is
broken down that both R and DJ asento
come out of their garage dispatch make
note that they uh they basically was
inside the house once they saw us reach
they came out the garage
door immediately deputies called them
out saying there's no way they didn't
hear their 10 minutes worth of knocking
there's no way in the world you didn't
hear us knocking at that door it off the
keys down the keys
down throw the keys
down you got any guns KN weapons
anything on you need we we need to know
about nothing at all at all why did you
guys come to the door why didn't you
come to the door we banged why are you
shaking so why are you so so why you so
why you shaking you guys just came out
of nowhere and I okay you came out of
nowhere you heard us knocking on that
door the whole time we literally are
going you didn't hear us knocking we're
banging the hell out of the door why
didn't you guys open come to the door
the door downstairs we banged pretty
hard you shaking so why you so so why
you so why you Shak you guys just came
out of nowhere and shower okay you came
out of nowhere you heard us knocking on
that door the whole time
you didn't hear us knocking we're
banging the hell out of the door my
hands are R banging out the door and you
didn't hear us we're downstairs anybody
else inside I'm sorry nobody else is
inside I'm sorry I don't know what's
going on what's your first name uh Kyla
spell it for me k y l a a r c e whoa
whoa whoa k y l a a r c e a r c e yes
how do you spell
say k y l Sor you guys had to come out
here you guys would open the door you
would this is brand new no I'm good
thank you what's your
uh
0219 what's your last name Ace e Ace so
it's Kyla a rce yeah what's your middle
name um in like in like driver s you
have a middle name well it's kandra s r
are you guys married no okay do you live
here with him what's going on here why
are we getting calls from your neighbors
that they're hearing glass brakes and
they're hearing stuff being thrown
around what's going on with you guys
nothing nothing's going on we were
watching a show list listen to me listen
me I got information from Neighbors all
night long help me help me you're
hurting me stuff breaking stop doing
this what's going on but like would
I come take a walk with me I don't want
to walk with you come with me can I just
sit down no come with me what from here
the sheriff's deputies separate the pair
let's talk away from your your friend
wrong I don't feel I'm not saying you
did anything wrong okay I'm just asking
about what's going on why are your
neighbors saying what's going why are
your neighbors saying all this about you
about you're screaming for help help
that's why we had to break in your door
your door is broken the fireman popped
it you're going to have to get the
association to fix your
door are you serious I'm dead serious
all right we're banging on the door
banging on the like I just told you my
hands are red and his hands are red from
banging on the door there is no way you
could not hear us I'm so sorry what's
going on nothing at all I promise you
nothing at all not pressing charges
nothing at all not pressing why would
you not press charges I don't even know
how to say of the cop thing but why
would you not press charges about what
if you said you wouldn't press charges
what would you not press charges I mean
I just said that to just cuz I don't
know what's going on nothing's going on
100% how long you been we're watching
we've been together for two years we're
good no problems ever problem neighbors
that have been hearing things throughout
the middle of the night nothing's going
on nothing's going on so they're lying
literally they yesterday my freaking
plants fell from the backyard and I just
started cry crying because I just
couldn't do it at late at night maybe
that's it so then what you tell me is
all the neighbors standing out here
behind me that called us and your
neighbors that live on your floor there
the second floor there are all L I'm not
saying they're lying I don't know what
their perception ising for help okay and
the fact that we're banging and banging
and banging and once we get in you guys
try to pull away because we're not I
don't I didn't really hear you like that
you guys in the garage the whole time
we're no we're like sitting in the room
we're about to go get breakfast and you
didn't hear us banging on the door oh
that's kler I I find that hard to
believe we were ringing the bell okay
soell sorry I'm sorry did your did your
bell go go to the phone or his phone so
why do you guys have a video Bell um it
doesn't go to mine I does it go to his I
don't know come here come here come talk
to me for a
minute what's your name again all right
Deputy Allen Bro Look situation didn't
even have to go this far well I don't
know what it's talking about I get it I
don't know what's going you're shaking
like it's like yeah because who would
not only that you got scratches all over
you and stuff like that what's going on
talk to me I have no idea what's going
on you tell you tell it exactly how we
have you how do you have nothing what's
going on dude you're coming out of the
garage you're shaking like crazy you got
scratches off I get it I'm shaking cuz
all of a sudden someone just block so
you live here with someone else that's
just that's by myself
you live here by yourself or she who is
she to you she's my girlfriend okay so
who was the other dude that was here a
friend okay so what
happened nothing we just hang out we
watch TV and that's it but everybody was
yelling and screaming you got neighbors
over here and people people don't even
live here saying that she was screaming
at the top of her lungs something was
going on look I'm not trying to make a
story up I don't understand and I don't
want to I don't want to make you feel
uncomfortable more than what you are in
the situation but the thing is bro we're
trying to find out this is more of a
life or death situation it's called
circumstan what's going on out of
nowhere so that's what I'm confused
about so why would we KN not on the door
you just didn't come to the door we're
downstairs I'm in the shower she's
watching the show and then we're
downstairs yeah all right check it out
this is the garage I know the format of
these cuz I've been in one that's your
downstairs right here your upstairs is
up there just hear me out cuz you live
here right you pay rent here I mean you
pay your mortgage here every month right
so the thing is I know the difference
this is downstairs you weren't
downstairs we were knocking on this door
there's a bedroom down here on the
bottom okay that's fine okay but I'm
pretty sure you heard us banging on this
door I didn't hear
anything okay look I look I can't I
can't make you tell us what's going on
all the time I hear things going all the
time so I don't know what is what when
you live right next to each other you
hear things all the time so well your
neighbors and everybody heard you
screaming and no heard her screaming
like
something was wrong and then she's not
answering so therefore that gives us
even more of a suspicious inent where we
got to go and find out who who's alive
and who's dead or or see if anybody's
okay that's where we're coming from okay
I mean yeah but everyone's fine I mean I
get it
okay so do me a favor you said it's a
bedroom right here open this up for me
I'm not going to open door there's no
reason well we've already opened the
door I'm just asking you to open it up
cuz we go back up cuz I can go back up
and go back in I'm already I've already
have look look look I have a I have a
lawful right to be in that home to make
sure nothing's going okay so open the
door let us check and then we're good
what is it what is a reason I understand
she's
here yeah he's saying it's a bedroom
down there that's okay you don't have
you don't have to cooperate we we're
good I just asked him to open the thing
cuz uh it's so the door is already open
and we have lawful right to be here so
just open the thing KY if they think
someone else is in the house that's what
they're trying to say to me we want to
make sure everyone's the house yeah
there's no one else in here okay well
open it up okay well open it up then for
what okay well I'll just go I just go
upstairs and
go I just asked him
that that's all I
said everything is being recorded here
throughout this all the couple continues
to tell conflicting stories as R
repeatedly apologizes you said nobody
else is here he just said his friend was
here and his friend just left now tell
me the truth yeah but I'm downstairs
there's too many listen to what I just
said yeah you just told myself and this
Deputy that nobody else is here he said
his friend was here and his friend left
so now you're saying that so now you got
she may not know cuz she doesn't go
upstairs to see well how do you not know
when you've been in the house all time
there three like like it's it's too much
I barely hear anybody downstairs I work
on my computer and nothing's going on I
don't know if was he but Ry maintains
she's okay and doesn't need any help so
you're safe everything's good
everything's good look at me okay look
at my face I'm good and how long have
yall been together sorry you guys couple
years couple years y'all have any
children involved I'm trying to you're
trying to okay you guys Mar mared just
boyfriend and girlfriend just been
dating I mean I
didn't we not done yet but in the future
if we're knocking the door just hi hello
look at now your door's off the hinge so
and you have to fix that
seriously because the exent
circumstances due to the State of
Florida if anybody's in in dire danger
or anything like that we have to respond
any could be yelling out any window and
you can't pick no I mean I know that no
one's here anymore but everyone of your
neighbors is standing outside coning
with your so we're knocking on the
door you see what I'm saying okay now I
get it I didn't know that you said oh I
didn't need and I'm not talking about
two people we're talking about four or
five people out here saying that they
heard you
screaming I mean nothing he just he left
but I'm only one here about I'm the only
one maybe just I don't you I see the
perspective my supervis actually direct
figure I mean nothing I just yelling
about nothing just like going around
yelling at for no reason I wasn't
yelling at screaming like that neighbor
standing telling we know what happened
we're wondering why okay just yelling
and screaming what were you doing it's
not not it's not normal to
yell look we're not here look basically
we're not we're not here to get y'all in
trouble we're not here so I bad saying
is that someone's screaming and then the
mail came out like so rapidly yeah and
they also gave us the perfect
description they said you two were still
inside yeah so I guess I see what you're
saying
okay all right all right my bad I'm
sorry
um yeah nothing's going on since there's
only three Fe I'm I'm the female I'm a
good all good I promise just 36 days
after this video was recorded DJ rinto
allegedly shot and killed AR he now
faces charges of murder attempted murder
and resisting arrest with violence
reporting for long crime Network I'm I'm
SI Gillespie